ein Mann von außerordentlichen Mut er
wollte zunächst einmal die Kinder
schützen für die zuständig war Präsident
von der Leyen und ich stehen geeint da
für alle
Führer in Nordirland und diejenigen die
versuchen uns zurückzubringen in die
Vergangenheit werden niemals Erfolg
haben ich habe Präsidentin von der Laien
heute in Winzer begrüßt um unsere
Gespräche über das
nordirland-protokoll vorzuführen und es
freut mich Ihnen bitte teilen zu können
dass wir jetzt einen entschiedenen
Durchbruch
erreichte haben wir haben das
ursprüngliche Protokoll verändert und
verkünden heute das neue Winzer Portugal
damit soll der Handel ungehindert in
Vereinigten Königreich von starken
Kinder Nordirland wird geschützt und
auch diese Souveränität
in Nordirland leicht waren diese
Verhandlungen nicht immer aber ich
möchte
Ursula wirklich würdigen sie hat die
Vision entwickelt dass es hier doch eine
Lösungsmöglichkeit gibt und nicht darf
mich bei allen bedanken die sich dafür
eingesetzt haben in der Vergangenheit
hatten wir sicherlich unsere
Schwierigkeiten aber wir sind wirklich
Partner Handelspartner und Freunde im
letzten Jahr haben wir das unter Beweis
gestellt als wir gemeinsam die Ukraine
unterstützt haben und das ist jetzt der
Beginn eines neuen Kapitels in unserem
Verhältnis über 25 Jahre war das Belfast
der
Karfreitagsabkommen entscheiden denn es
würdigte ja auch die Bestrebungen und
die
Identitäten aller
Gemeinschaften auf die irischen Insel
und mit dem in Protokoll können wir
einen Weg aufzeigen für die Menschen in
Nordirland ich stehe hier weil ich meine
wir haben Mittel und Wege gefunden um
die Unsicherheit für die Menschen in
Nordirland zu beenden wir haben drei
große Schritte nach vorne getan erstens
mit dem heutigen abkommen kann der
Warenverkehr reibungslos erfolgen Güter
die in Nordirland verbleiben können über
eine Green Lane
eingeführt werden und die die weiter in
den EU Binnenmarkt gehen gehen über die
Redline aber diejenigen die über die
Green Lane gehen die bedeuten eine
Erleichterung weil nicht mehr hunderte
von Bescheinigung und Zertifikaten
notwendig sind und eben auch
entsprechende Produkte aus große
Britannien in nordirlande verkauft
werden können also wenn Sie die Waren in
Großbritannien gibt es ja auch
Nordirland und im Gegensatz zum
Protokoll ist es auch mit der heutigen
Einigung so dass wenn man Päckchen und
Pakete versendet oder empfängt muss man
keine
Zollpapiere mehr ausfüllen das heißt wir
haben jeglichen Anklang einer Grenze im
irischen Meer vermieden wir haben dann
auch den Rechtstext des Protokolls
ergänzt um Veränderungen bei der
Mehrwertsteuer und bei den Verbrauchs
Abgaben vorzunehmen z.B beim Alkohol
sprich all das was sie im Großbritannien
jetzt schon geregelt haben für die Pops
wird auch in Nordirland gelten auch
alles was für Pflanzen sagt Kartoffeln
und so weiter Großbritannien wird jetzt
auch in Nordirland der gelten also sehr
viele Auflagen auch für Haustiere wurden
aufgehoben außerdem haben wir uns
geeinigt was
Arzneimittel anbelangt also alle vom
britischen Medizin Regulierer
zugelassenen Arzneimittel werden auch
sofort in allen Apotheken und
Krankenhäusern in den Nordirlands
verfügbar und drittens
garantieren wir die Souveränität der
Menschen in Nordirland mit diesem
Abkommen und das einzige was dort gilt
sind die Regeln die vermeiden sondern
das ist zu einer harten Grenze mit
Nordirland bzw mit Irland ich weiß viele
Menschen in Nordirland machen sich
Sorgen wenn es um Veränderungen beim
eu-richtung Warenverkehr anbelangt
deshalb haben wir mit der heutigen ähm
auch eine Bremsfunktion für den Sommer
eingeführt
also das noch die irische Parlament kann
verhindern dass bestimmte Regeln genau
Nordirland gelten damit haben wir ein
klares Prozess also das eben die
parlamentarische Versammlung zur Note
auf die Bremse treten kann wenn
Regelungen sich auf das tägliche Leben
der Bevölkerung in Nordirland auswirken
und wenn Nordirland diese Bremse
betätigt hat auf die britische Regierung
ein WE Touristen damit haben wir
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen eingeführt und
ich denke dieses win
regelt die praktischen Probleme die die
Menschen in Nordirland haben und es
bewahrt auf das Karfreitagsabkommen
natürlich wollen alle Beteiligten das
Ganze im Detail prüfen also das dauert
seine Zeit man muss das auch sorgfältig
prüfen die heute
nicht verfasst zum Text von Verträgen
und Gesetzen aber es geht um sehr viel
mehr es geht um die Stabilität in
Nordirland es geht um Menschen es geht
um Unternehmen es geht darum dass wir
zeigen dass unsere Union die über Jahr
auch hunderte bestanden hat auch
weiterhin bestehen kann und wird und wir
wollen die Grenzen zwischen uns
niederreißen wir wollen die Argumente
beiseiteschieben die uns nur allzu lange
getrennt haben und wir sollten wieder
das erleben was uns ausmacht als Familie
von Nationen im Vereinigten Königreich
vielen Dank
Prime Minister
lieber Richie es ist für mich eine Ehre
und Freude hier in Winzer mit Ihnen
zusammen zu treffen und ich bin auch
sehr zufrieden und in diesem Gefühl
stehen wir vermeide ich hier wir haben
eine wichtige Zusage die wir einander
von paar Monaten gegeben haben umgesetzt
die ich erinnere mich an unsere ersten
Gespräche als wir uns darüber
unterhalten haben wie wir unsere Freunde
in der Ukraine unterstützen konnten und
ich war ermutigt durch unsere
vertrauensvolle Zusammenarbeit bei
dieser wichtigen Virus strategischen
frage ich kann mich aber auch daran
erinnern dass wir beide ehrlich waren
einander gegenüber was die
Schwierigkeiten in unseren bilateralen
Beziehungen anbelangt und es war auch
wichtig dass man das auf die richtige
Grundlage setzt wir haben einander
versprochen hat zu arbeiten und wir
wussten wenn es uns gelingen würde das
Potenzial unserer Partnerschaft voll
auszuschöpfen dass wir da Lösungen
brauchten im Zusammenhang mit dem
Nordirland Protokoll wir wussten auch
das würde nicht leicht werden
wir wussten dass wir einander zuhören
mussten die Bedenken der anderen Seite
auch sorgfältig aufnehmen aber vor allen
Dingen mussten wir auch hören auf die
Bedenken der Menschen in Nordirland wir
muss wussten dass wir hart arbeiten
müssten entschlossen aber wir wussten
auch lieber Richie das ist uns gelingen
würde das zu erreichen denn wir waren
beide voll engagiert wir wollten eine
praktische Lösung finden für die
Menschen und für alle Gemeinden in
Nordirland heute
können wir stolz darauf hinweisen dass
wir geliefert haben wir haben diese
Zusage eingehalten heute haben wir eine
grundsatzreinigung erzielt zum Rahmen
von Windsor diese Rahmen liegt
Neubestimmung für Irland und Nordirland
fest und mit diesen neuen Rahmenwerk
können wir auch ein neues Kapitel
beginnt er liefert langfristige Lösung
und wir beide sind zuversichtlich dass
das für alle Menschen und Unternehmen in
Nordirland funktionieren wird Lösungen
die auch direkt Eingehen auf die
Bedenken die von ihnen vorgetragen
wurden Herr Premierminister wir haben
eine Fülle von
Themen behandelt und die neuen
Regelungen stellen einen umfassendes
Paket da also dass wir nun endgültig die
Probleme angehen können die sich im
täglichen Leben einstellen ich möchte
nur zwei Beispiele nennen die für mich
besonders berät sind in der neue Winzer
Rahmen stellt sicher dass dieselben
Nahrungsmittel im Supermarkt in
Nordirland genauso wie im übrigen
Vereinigten Königreich verfügbar sind
und dieses neue Rahmenwerk wird dafür
sorgen dass alle Arzneimittel auch neu
achten in Nordirland irgendwelche
gleichzeitig und unter denselben
Bedingungen wie im Vereinigten
Königreich verfügbar sein wird insofern
haben wir auch starke
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen eingezogen wie
Zugriff auf IT-Systeme um auch die
Integrität des
eu-bittenmarktes zu schützen dieses neue
Rahmenwerk respektiert und schützt
unsere jeweiligen Märkte und unsere
jeweiligen legitimen Interessen und vor
allen Dingen schützt es
den hart errungen Frieden im Rahmen des
Belfast
Karfreitagsabkommen für die Menschen in
Nordirland und überall auf der irischen
Insel Gewalt hat in unseren
Gesellschaften keinen Platz ich
verurteile zu tiefste
die Erschießung eines Tieres in all
Offiziers in der letzten Woche und mein
Mitgefühl gilt ihm und dann Angehörigen
in diesem Jahr wird der 25 jahrestag des
Karfreitagsabkommen begangen ein
wichtiger Meilenstein in diesem
historischen
Friedensprozess das neue
windsor-rahmenwerk soll den Menschen in
Nordirland helfen und allen die sich für
Frieden auf der irischen Insel einsetzen
die und deshalb glaube ich dass wir
jetzt ein neues Kapitel in unserer
Partnerschaft eröffnen können
foundationship stärker Beziehung
zwischen der EU und dem Vereinigten
Königreich enge Partner Schulter an
Schulter stehen wir heute und auch in
Zukunft beieinander
wir hätten jetzt Zeit für einige fragen
wir beginnen mit der BBC
wenn die DOP in Nordirland nicht wieder
in die Regierung
zurückkehrt nach all diesen bedeutet das
dann nicht doch ein Scheitern für sie ja
ich denke heute
haben wir einen Wendepunkt für
Nordirland erreicht
ich habe mir angehört was die Menschen
was die Unternehmen was die Wirtschaft
dort vorgetragen hat ich verstehe Ihre
Bedenken und ich denke die heutige
Rahmenregelungen
sicher also es bedeutet das ist keine
Hindernisse Warenverkehr mehr gibt und
es bedeutet eine Unterstützung der
Souveränität der ich verstehe natürlich
dass man in Nordirland erstmal Zeit
braucht um in detail das zu prüfen was
wir heute vereinbart haben und das
respektiere ich ja auch von und ganz ich
denke was wir heute erreicht haben ist
wirklich ein Durchbruch
und jetzt müssen die beteiligten
Parteien
entscheiden wie sie weiter verfahren
wollen um eine bessere Zukunft für
Nordirland zu gestalten was wir heute
vereinbart haben ist historisch so sehe
ich das und sicherlich wird sehr viel
passieren
zum Beispiel die Einrichtung der Green
Lanes und Red Lanes für die waren
das paperwork das bedeutet sehr viel
weniger Papierkram weniger Zoll
Kontrollen vor Ort
Austausch von zolldaten in Echtzeit all
das zu einer drastischen Erleichterung
des Warenverkehrs führen dass es
wirklich ein großer Schritt nach vorne
und ich denke es ist uns auch gelungen
eine Einigung und Lösung zu finden die
unseren Binnenmarkt hier schützt und das
ist wirklich sehr viel was wir erreicht
haben und deshalb bedanke ich mich für
die ausgezeichnete Zusammenarbeit ich
bedanke mich auch bei all unseren Teams
für die Zeit heute und ihren
Sachverstand den sie mit in die
Verhandlungen gesteckt haben ja also wir
Ursula auch möchte ich unseren Teams
herzlich danken ich rufe anders
gesagt hat hoffe ich konzentrieren wir
uns immer auf die politische Seite aber
hier geht's ja um die Menschen in
Nordirland die Unternehmen dort und um
das was für die am besten ist und ich
denke dass die Rahmenregelung die wir
heute vereinbart haben den Problemen
gerecht wird und die Menschen werden in
den Mittelpunkt gestellt um ihre Zukunft
selbst zu bestimmen und das ist wirklich
ein großer Durchbruch und ich hoffe dass
das alle auch erkennen werden ich denke
es wird schon unmittelbar Erleichterung
für die Menschen in Nordirland geben ich
denke darüber können wir uns doch alle
freuen
a.t.i als nächstes
sagen sie wollen genauso behandelt
werden
jeder andere Zahl im Vereinigten
Königreich aber Nordirland ist ja der
einzige Teil des heiligen Königreiches
mit der eu-hater
werden diese unterschiedliche Behandlung
akzeptieren und wie sieht es mit der
Zuständigkeit des Europäischen
Gerichtshofes in Nordirland aus
ich kann im Grunde nur das wiederholen
was ich jedem schon gerade gesagt habe
natürlich ist die Politik wichtig und
die Parteien in Nordirland die
Unionisten werden sicherlich Zeit
brauchen um das zu prüfen was wir heute
verkündet haben und wir werden Ihnen
auch die entsprechende Zeit einordnen
aber wenn sie sich die Menschen
anschauen die Familien und Ihr
Unternehmen ich denke die werden
erkennen dass das was wir heute
vereinbart haben erhebliche
Verbesserungen für ihr Leben darstellen
und dass er durch das Protokoll doch
einige Unterbrechungen und Störungen
erfahren ich denke sie werden das
Erkennen und sie werden auch sehr
schnell die Vorteile erkennen
ja es gibt ja viele Dinge die immer
wieder auftauchen im Gespräch mit den
Menschen in Nordirland aber in dieser
Rahmen ist ja sehr breit gesteckt und
ich denke wir decken damit alle Probleme
ab und sichern auf die Souveränität und
nicht weiß das ist für die Menschen
Nordirland wirklich sehr wichtig nun zur
Rolle des EU-Rechtes
mit der Zustimmung der Menschen in
Nordirland hat Nordirland Zugang zum
Binnenmarkt und ich denke wir allen
wollen ja hier harte Grenzen zwischen
Nordirland und der Republik Irland
vermeiden
und deshalb wie gesagt wird die EU-Recht
in Nordirland angewand aber mit der
Zustimmung der
Beteiligten und mit der heutigen
Einigung haben wir noch mehr
demokratische
Rechenschaftslegung eingebaut mit diesem
Bremsmechanismus für den sturmen also
insofern kann der sturment das
nordirische Parlamente auf die Bremse
treten wenn er da Auffassung dass es
hier demokratische Defizite gibt um
sicherzustellen dass Nordirland wirklich
über sein Schicksal bestimmen kann ja
der EuGH ist letztlich die Instanz die
über EU Recht befindet der europäische
Gerichtshofe wird also bei EU Recht und
Fragen die den Binnenmarkt betreffen das
letzte Wort haben aber im Rahmen dieses
winterrahmenwerks haben wir uns
konzentriert nicht nur auf die Rolle des
eu-gh sondern auch auf andere
cheatsverfahren und da haben wir eben
diesen neuen Bremsmechanismus für den
Sommer und der fußten wir natürlich
unsere Regelungen auf den
Friedensprozess der im
Karfreitagsabkommen mündete also wir
meinen wir haben den Mechanismus
verbessert und wichtig ist dass wir auch
ein paar mechanis geschafft haben die es
verhindern dass man überhaupt diese
stormen Notbremse betätigt also es gibt
extensive
konsultationsgespräche mit dem
peinlichen Königreich und Nordirland
wenn es um neue
EU-Gesetze gibt und wenn es Änderungen
bei den Regeln auch im Gesundheits- und
Pflanzen gesundheitlichen Bereich kommt
und was nun Irland und Nordirland
anbelangt
so hat die Europäische Union immer
wieder gesagt
sie will das Karfreitag Abkommen auf
alle Fälle hochhalten keine harte Grenze
auf der irischen Insel aber wir wollen
natürlich auch die Integrität des EU
Binnenmarktes schützen als nächstes der
Express
vielen Dank von Lilly
expresse für ihre politische
Führungsrolle
also die Frage ist wie wird Boris
Johnson reagieren und die European
research group innerhalb der
konservativen Partei das war die Frage
an Sie Frage an Frau von der Leyen
wieso ist es dem jetzigen
Premierminister gelungen zuständige
Zugeständnisse aus verhandeln während es
seine drei Amtsvorgänger nicht geschafft
haben ja ich denke natürlich muss das
ganze auf dem Karfreitagsabkommen aber
alle brauchen Zeit um das ganze zu
prüfen im Detail das ist ja eine
umfassende Regelung die Leute brauchen
ihre Zeit das verstehe ich nicht aber es
geht nicht um mich es geht nicht um
Politiker sondern es geht um die
Menschen in Nordirland was für die das
Beste ist es geht um die Familien um die
Unternehmen und wie deren Leben
verbessert werden kann durch dieses
Rahmenwerk und ich denke die Veränderung
die wir vorgenommen haben und den
Durchbruch den wir erreicht haben all
das wird sehr viel bewirken wir können
jetzt sagen Waren werden frei innerhalb
des britischen Binnenmarktes verkehren
können wir haben die Souveränität der
Menschen in Nordirland gewahrt das sind
ja alles doch erheblicherrungenschaften
und darauf sollten wir uns konzentrieren
ich denke wir alle wissen natürlich dass
wir Stabilität in Nordirland brauchen
wissen wie wichtig das Abkommen ist und
mit dem heutigen Rahmenwerk stellen wir
dieses Gleichgewicht wieder her und
insofern ist es ein Schritt nach vorne
an Wendepunkt für die Menschen
Nordirland ich hoffe dass sie jetzt auch
auf eine bessere Zukunft blicken kann
ich denke man sollte festhalten dass wir
beide als wir uns zum allerersten Mal
Treffen vereinbart hatten das wenn man
sich den großen Herausforderungen wir
gemeinsam
also dieser fürchterliche russische
Krieg in der Ukraine oder der Kampf
gegen den Klimawandel also da haben wir
so viele gemeinsame
Dinge wir kämpfen für dieselben Werte
wir sehen es stehen Schulter an Schulter
und wir wollen die bestmögliche Lösung
für die Menschen in Nordirland in der
jetzigen Situation also da gab es eine
sehr konstruktive Haltung und das von
Anfang an um Probleme zu lösen und
praktische Lösungen zu finden für das
tägliche Leben der Menschen Unternehmen
das aber auch getan wir haben die
Lösungen gemeinsam entwickelt
wir brauchen sehr viel guten Willen und
wissen also das haben wir jetzt
gemeinsam
verabredet und ich bin sehr glücklich
über diese Einigung die wir im Rahmen
des windsor-rahmenwerks erzielt haben
und noch eine letzte Frage
jetzt besteht wieder Vertrauen zwischen
dem VK und der EU und meinen sie dass
das war einige Königreich dann auch
wirklich dann wieder
mitarbeiten können im Rahmen von Horizon
ja ja dieses Rahmenwerk von Winzer ist
auch eine gute Nachricht für Forscher
und Wissenschaftler in der EU und in der
im Vereinigten Königreich
denn also wenn dieses Abkommen
umgesetzt wird dann bin ich also
wirklich ganz bereit sofort auch mit den
Arbeiten an einem Assoziierungsabkommen
zu Beginn das ist die Voraussetzung
dafür im Rahmen von Horizon Europe
mitzuwirken das ist also eine gute
Nachricht für alle Forscher ja es gibt
ja eine ganze Reihe von verschiedenen
Bereichen in denen wir produktiv
zusammenarbeiten können und die
Präsidentin und ich haben damit schon
begonnen als wir uns zum ersten Mal
trafen schauen sich die Lage in der
Ukraine an da mussten wir uns ja eng
absprechen auch bei den Sanktionen aber
auf das Thema
Energieversorgungssicherheit weil unsere
Energiemärkte ja miteinander verknickt
sind dann Klimawandel
illegale Migration also das sind die
Dinge bei denen wir durch unsere
Zusammenarbeit Fortschritte machen
können zum Wohle alle unsere Wähler und
Gemeinden die mir vertreten und da freue
ich mich auf eine weitere Zusammenarbeit
gut vielen Dank damit wären wir am Ende
dieser Konferenz angelangt
zwei strahlende Politiker Ursula von der
Leyen und der britische Premier Richie
sunek da geht offenbar wieder viel viel
mehr zwischen London und Brüssel als zu
der Zeit von Boris Johnson jedenfalls
heute dieses sogenannte winsor-abkommen
eine große Einigung man muss dann sicher
das Kleingedruckte lesen wie das Ganze
dann ratifiziert und umgesetzt werden
kann ob es ein Zusatzprotokoll wird zum
brexit-abkommen fest steht jedenfalls
ist eine Einigung gefunden für den
Handel zwischen auf der einen Seite
Großbritannien und Nordirland auf der
anderen Seite zwischen Nordirland und
Irland der Republik dass er Teil der
Europäischen Union ist sie haben die
beiden gehört das ganze ist offenbar
zustande gekommen weil es eine
vertrauensvolle Zusammenarbeit im
Hinblick auf die Unterstützung der
Ukraine seit mehr als einem Jahr gegeben
hat also eine bemerkenswerte Entwicklung
auch irgendwie herbeige führt durch den
Vernichtungskrieg von Wladimir Putin
gegenüber der Ukraine so viel dazu